the screws er looks like a big scooter
but it's not for kids
powered by an electric motor it can zip
up to speeds of 25 kilometers per hour
it's allowed on bike ways and even
sidewalks in Germany not just on the
street
Dresden based business consultants Timur
developed it
ah swaggins and proxies at wat suan it
was simple walking bug-brain and driving
a car was even worse especially for
short distances in talentless I needed
something that suited me
cycling wasn't my style right here and
it had to be different from what you see
on the streets
Honda's is ice dust bus last month off
James Carson's eat the 50 year old let's
pass us by and rest and take his
prototypes for a test scrim tema
designed this cruiser but led a team of
engineers put it together it took them
two years to come up with the screws er
you can sit or stand while you're right
fancies poor it's cool and fun like a
skateboard but way faster fish Nana
spina exciting but different from a bike
I thought I was gonna drive into this
window okay it's like deja McLouth whole
time harness hog great to drive great
fog a few spots most energy fun doesn't
keep you fit though fitness like an
electric bicycle the electric scooter
has an impulse Drive it knows how much
speed the rider is generating and
multiplies this all of the parts are
made in Germany
but the name was inspired by some
English words
a blonde over leaked well I thought long
and hard and put together lots of words
and I ended up with screws off the wall
Nana community combination of scooter
and cruisin owned em causing more and
more electrically powered vehicles are
coming onto the market and some are
really unique the Segway for example
invented in the US and 2001 it's used
primarily for tourism today but police
and Braman are also using them in a
pilot patrolling project electric
bicycles are becoming more and more
popular two estimates indicate that
there are 1.3 million of them on Germany
streets today the deputy head of the
Berlin Agency for electro mobility
Thomas Meisner predicts that in two
decades about half of all bikes will be
electrically powered he says there will
be a niche market for thus cruiser and
Segway as well
let's get monoi the inland CIL's among
with the Elector believe there are
always new ideas regarding electoral
mobility they put a fog of beauty and
that depends on what electric vehicles
offer I ease the burden on city streets
particularly because their emissions
free and quiet really decisive factors
in cities and they can be powered with
renewable energies meaning they also
help protect the environment on the size
of VD t wash was problematic I'll be
sticking by Tatsu lies but electric
vehicle technology comes at a price a
squeezer sells for around four thousand
euros fingers it's okay that it costs
four thousand euros finding you've come
back to a used car for two thousand
euros it's a bit hot yeah I mean it's a
it's fun ultimately but four grand for
fun is a lot of money if you get
finished Fugate that if I had lots of
money then it would be a cool machine
two ways around town and in the
pedestrian zone hangouts on its lights
yen steamer wants his cruiser to appeal
to affluent urbanites
people who make lots of little trips and
aren't into more conventional means of
transport Eastern before--this we're
talking about urban mobility or electric
mobility now in 2013 we're at the very
beginning it's going to develop enormous
li traffic will increase people will
need alternatives and I always imagine
someday I'll be sitting in Buenos Aires
and a sprues er will go by and that'll
make me so happy
huzzah for bio and for misters we
the screws er will be available in shops
from May next year 60 orders have
already come in from around the globe